several weeks have passed both the
caretaking team and the anti-poaching
unit agree it's time to slide those
poles aside there is no fanfare no
marching band just the gentle opening of
a gateway and withdrawn now it is all up
to you
into a brave new world 12 years it's a
third of a rhino's laughs a lot can
change a lot can be forgotten
everything is new smells sights sounds
but the first rhinos back in the wild
take to it like giant sailing ships
under a strong wind
they all go cautiously into the unknown
stepping carefully like the first man on
the moon
as if desperate to leave no scent and
two ghosts off into the life before and
other human notices that they're
actually free